are you guys you and today yeah crazy
day good I mean it sincerely when I say
thank you so much for coming in I'm
super happy to be talking to all of you
guys about the film before we get
started I have to say that the only
reason I get to be at Sundance and the
only reason the collider gets to be at
Sundance is because of our sponsorships
because we have a great relationship
with Kia and their new Telluride I just
want to give them a big thank you for
sponsoring Collider because I really
wanted to be here and you know Sundance
I heard is expensive so I just want to
say a huge thank you jumping into I get
to talk to you guys today
you guys get to premiere tonight at
Sundance I'm sure when you were making
this you I mean you're never really sure
what's gonna happen but what does it
mean for all of you guys to be here
premiering at Sundance it's amazing you
know luckily for whatever reason
Sundance has really liked my stuff over
the years you know I've premiered about
six documentaries and this will be my
first scripted movie to premiere and
that Sundance Seal of Approval because
it this is really you know the film is
an intelligent layered film it's not
some gory catalog of bundy killings
there's a real reason that we're making
this film and to come here is amazing i
mean it's just it's like the it's like
the Good Housekeeping Seal of Approval
for an indie film and that's what we are
well the other thing that I think is
really interesting and I think what
people might not be expecting is that
this is not the movie that I think maybe
people are thinking it's gonna be it's
more told from your perspective and
obviously there's a lot to it but it's
more about how did you not know and
there's a lot of different layers to
this thing can you sort of talk about
that aspect of the film yeah I'm for me
part of what was so intriguing about the
script and talking to Joe about
Elizabeth who I play was the idea that
this is really a story where we get to
feel empathy for a victim who is still
alive Joe and I got to visit her and her
daughter and ask her questions about
about Bundy and about their relationship
and I got to hold handwritten notes that
he had written her and see photos that
no one has ever seen before
and to hear her experience with this
story and to feel what she went through
felt so relatable not not that I've been
in her situation but every young woman
dates and goes out and you think that
you know who somebody is and sometimes
they turn out to be something different
and for us to be able to tell a story
that everyone thinks they know from one
perspective and actually show it from a
victim's perspective and just kind of
show how she was duped for lack of
better words um and I was saying
actually earlier that you know Joe's
work he normally physically frees the
wrongfully accused in this he frees the
victim and it was emotional for her to
finally figure out what was going on and
you really see that in the journey for
her for her and for Bundy I'm curious
what for you you're playing someone
revolting someone awful and I'm curious
how much debate did you have on taking
on this role and was it like a big
debate you know what I mean and how you
guys talked about it debate I don't
think was there was never a debate for
me I initially I did not I was I would
didn't want to do it at all really I
thought I didn't I thought that it was I
thought I was like any any concept
whatever I'm gonna read in this script
is going to be too heavy-handed gory
thriller it's gonna be desperate or
something I don't have no idea I don't
see how this could ever work and then I
heard Joe was attached to film it and I
thought that was very interesting
considering his body of work and he
added a lot of credibility to it and
when I read the script I knew why he
wanted to do it because it wasn't mm-hmm
it's not your everyday hack-and-slash
yeah I don't know biopic about a serial
killer we're not following him around
and seeing the mass destruction or are
we celebrating it in any way mm-hmm but
um really taking it from the perspective
of what it's like to be manipulated as
some somebody who was probably the
closest person to Ted Bundy
ever and also on a you know on a
worldwide perspective you know the whole
world the people that are really
fascinated by Ted Bundy and people that
had lived
they talk about remembering the trial
and the most the craziest thing was that
they didn't know until the very end
whether he did it or not
like people really sincerely believed
that he was a stand-up positive
interesting loving good dude and that is
it couldn't be further from the truth
but that's the kind of magic that he had
so I think once I once I realized and
spoke with Joe and I the cast was put
together a new Lily was interested I
think lending myself to it to this
particular guy had a sense of purpose
and honesty that was not not there when
just hear Ted Bundy for you guys I'm
very curious how you guys got involved
in the project and what what did you
take away from reading the script Thank
You Angela I was I think one of the the
last people to sign on so in the email
seeing all these names seeing Joe's name
and I felt like sending the email
immediately saying yes but I was
responsible and read the scripts very
quickly and yeah it's just it's a really
tough subject matter but is handled in
an unexpected way and and and by seeing
a lot of the story through Liz's eyes
and my opportunity to play this
character who is sort of trying to get
her to move beyond Bundy who has
imprisoned her in his own way you know
it's at sheep she may not be in prison
but she is totally consumed and you know
by his you know his lies and his
manipulation and everything and it's
just it's a really compelling
relationship they evolved between all
these people so it was an honor to be
part of it Angela by the way Hayley
keeps saying in these interviews he was
one of the last ones to sign on but the
reality is that everyone here were my
first choices which is amazing like you
know this is my first scripted endeavor
in a really long time and for all of
these actors to it my first choice of
actors to say yes is like a filmmakers
dream come true so you were you were one
of the last because we have all the had
all these
they're issues or whatever but just to
be clear you were my first choice for
that I really appreciate that I
well I knew Joe cuz we did a film a
documentary that I was a part of and I
was working on a film called the promise
and and Joe is doing a documentary about
the denial of the Armenian Genocide
called intent to destroy and I had been
a fan of his work I'd seen Paradise Lost
and a lot of his other work but really
learned more about it after I met him
and I'm incredibly impressed by his his
work not only beyond the film but what
he does in a social sense he fights for
for innocent lives who are accused of
crime and here he did the opposite and
he presented this script to me and I was
so honored that he wanted me to be a
part of it and so the part I play here
is really special because for me as a
woman to be able to play that voice of
reason in a lot of ways because I think
I do relate to to Liz the character and
having seen some of the footage on
YouTube about Ted Bundy presenting
himself as a lawyer in court which
apparently you said was the first time
in history to ever happen yeah the
cameras were in the court I was
astonished at how charming and
manipulative he was and how you start to
question is he really guilty could this
guy really have done it and so it's that
search for truth I think not being able
to see it when it's in front of you so I
think that's what the film covers I'm
very curious Joe
ultimately what you get on on location
what you're filming in the editing room
is the final rewrite and I'm curious
what you learned in the editing room
through early screenings that impacted
the finished film a good question
you know we shot a few scenes that
didn't make it into the film I think the
film we filled out a lot more of some of
Bundy's activities and the film felt
like in earlier cuts we were straying
from the love story and the love story
to me is really important whether he
truly loved her or not is one of
fundamental questions that drives the
film and is unanswerable but this is
this is the one person Bundy didn't kill
even though he had the opportunity to do
it and that is the nucleus as to why I
found the script fascinating and why I
had to do it because I've spent a lot of
time as Angela so nicely thank you said
you know I've spent a lot of time on
death row looking into the eyes of
people who are telling me they're
innocent and you have to go through a
process of understanding and believing
them in order to take the case on and
I've spent you know a few sleepless
sleepless nights in my hotel room well
what if I'm being snowed what if this is
not true and just for the record peridot
anyone I've actually finished the film
about I believe they're innocent but you
go through this vetting process and
there's an investigative process and the
fact that you you wonder if somebody is
telling you the truth kind of drives
what this film is about and you need to
do that through the love story because I
want the audience to take the same
emotional journey that Liz takes so even
though you know it's Bundy at the
beginning of the film I hope people will
suspend that knowledge and kind of go
into Lily's POV and understand how we
become seduced by this kind of
sociopathic behavior and so that love
story was critical so to answer your
question every time we strayed from the
love story in the early edits the film
kind of lost some of its energy so in
the editing process we slimmed the film
down tremendously to just give it this
kind of trajectory so that we're really
in Lily's POV now there are certain
things that happen in the film that Lily
is not there for so we say it's her POV
but it's really we're giving the
audience the experience that Lily had in
trusting and bonding and accepting who
this person is only to be Raval stand by
the truth at the end of the film so the
short answer is we were anytime we
walked away from the the love story of
the film kind of lost energy so we
tightened it up you obviously know a
great deal about his story through all
the things you've worked on I'm curious
talk a little bit about your you're
trying to tell the truth but you're also
making a movie so how do you tote that
line in terms of you know what I mean
like balancing that fact in fiction or
is everything we're seeing on screen
you know you know well truth is and
this'll sound maybe like heresy or
something but you know even the
documentary is not the the literal truth
of a situation you know filmmaking is
very subjective the literal truth of
Paradise Lost is if you were sitting in
a courtroom for six weeks the emotional
truth of Paradise Lost is Paradise Lost
and we only use about an hour of the
murder trial so it's about finding those
right moments so that you're capturing
the emotional truth of a situation as
opposed to the literal truth and so that
that that philosophy you know
transitioning to features that's what I
wanted to bring was just the emotional
truth of a situation so even if you take
some license like for example the final
scene of the movie which I don't want to
reveal is didn't happen the way it
happened it happened as as a phone call
and the phone call is far less dramatic
than a final real-life confrontation but
the emotional truth of what occurred in
that conversation whether it's done you
know in person or versus a phone it's
you're going for the same emotional
truth so that's that that's my
philosophy anyway I'm curious for for
all the actors and also for you before
filming begins you're looking at the
script you're seeing everything you got
to do what's the scene or maybe the
moment that you are like reading the
script you're like no I don't want to do
this scene this is going to suck i
without ruin anything it's the scene
that that Joe was just referencing at
the end of the movie it's a very long
scene with a lot of you word reading
that's yes there were lots of monologues
lots of it we you know we were in
abandoned prisons shooting and it's just
two people and it's just a very honest
scene but it was a lot to memorize a lot
of how I think I felt that way also
having spent time with Liz you want to
pay tribute to her and not that anyone
here knows how she acts or what she
feels but I got to meet her and to play
someone that's still alive that lived
through that that has purposefully kept
herself away from talking about this
stuff you know for a long time we never
wanted to end anyway jeopardize you know
what she's
kept to herself for so long and so that
scene was a real emotionally freeing
moment you know for my character and
it's pent up through many years and that
that scene it was just like it's like a
faceoff of sorts I guess you must read
it seen the most dreaded I don't think I
didn't dread any scenes I know that a
couple of scenes towards the beginning
of the movie when Ted is being like a
nice guy and and wooing Liz where's des
didn't come very natural they're loud
yeah be slick Ted Bundy's a real slick
well some of that did it was kind of
hard
there was a scene and I have a scene
with and that was I wasn't dreading it I
was definitely a little scared going
into that one because we John Malkovich
I couldn't believe that I was there I
was pretty there was nothing I dreaded
because I read the script and loved it
it was the first script that in a long
time that I felt like I had to do
because it deeply spoke to me so but you
know I was I guess the whole transition
to script it that was the more
intimidating part and thank God for my
cinematographer Brandon Drost who did an
amazing job and really kind of put his
arm around me and you know helped me
with that transition
I didn't mean dread as in like a
negative thing I wasn't like counting
title I was just very anxious like Mike
I totally dread it no I just was like
highly anxious no I I didn't think you
were dreading out of that I thought you
meant that like you're nervous about
filming it it's you nervous the whole
experience
no yet saying that Lily said you know
it's not like I you know I didn't really
have a choice because this was one of
those films that because of the tight
schedule I showed up in Cincinnati had a
costume fitting the next morning and
then we basically did like all of our
scenes the first day like slapped youth
day one yeah we had a little scuffle in
the living room in that house but it you
know it's just one of those things about
acting you just have to jump into it and
there's sometimes there's a lot of Merit
to a process where you get to rehearse
for weeks and weeks and weeks and then
you get to you know really plot things
out and then there's merit to some
things where a lot of reality and a lot
of energy comes out of the high wire act
of just being like okay we're doing it
it's happening right now and I think
that was really helpful in those scenes
you know and crucially that there's a
scene where I talked briefly to Zach on
the phone and we had you know had a
little earpiece or he had an earpiece
and we were actually talking on the
phone and like it just I felt
immediately immersed in the world you
know all these things happening in that
house so it was fun I don't think I
dreaded anything I or was really nervous
actually I was really looking forward to
doing some of the scenes because she's
very different than anything I've played
but I love finding little moments and
scenes you know like that you don't know
there was a there's a scene that Liz and
I were doing and Lily and I who plays
lights and she had some receipts on the
table and I because of the condition her
characters in I always thought I have to
search for what's really going on the
things that I don't know about her and
so I found it interesting that maybe I'm
reading her receipt while she's pouring
herself another drink
and so I liked finding little things
like that just a sec that's my alarm
Thanks but you know what I look forward
to was the courtroom scenes I was really
fascinated at seeing how that was gonna
come together because I had watched all
the YouTube videos so I was like that's
gonna be so cool to see which I'm not a
part of but I love that's the only thing
there's there's there's a quite a bit of
that footage and it was the first trial
ever
documented with in that capacity and put
put on TV so that's that we had to get
the closest to real life with that one
so anytime you're shooting for something
real or that really did transpire that's
where we it's we have we really have to
be careful with filling the line move
how close we take it under creative
license I was great at that I was gonna
say I could have a million other
questions but everyone over there is
giving me the hook like you need to
leave so I want to be respectful and you
don't need to leave
screw them we love you right I
appreciate that
however I do want to be able to talk to
you guys again in the future we should
they do control the door so I'm just
gonna say congrats on the movie I think
you're gonna have a great night tonight
thank you for real thank you very much
for having us thank you guys
you